STARR WHO JOINS US.
>> GENERAL AUSTIN HAS JUST
ISSUED A STATEMENT SAYING
ABSOLUTELY THE PLANE WAS NOT
SHOT DOWN.
HE WILL NOT SAY HOW IT WAS
BROUGHT DOWN.
HE ALSO SAYS THAT THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY WILL SUPPORT ANY
EFFORT TO RESCUE THE PILOT.
ISIS MILITANTS SEIZED THE
TERRIFIED JORDANIAN PILOT
CLAIMING THEY SHOT DOWN HIS F-16
OVER RAQQA, SYRIA, AN ISIS
STROCK HOLD.
HE IS THE NEPHEW OF A RETIRED
JORDANIAN GENERAL.
HIS CAPTURE, A FRIGHTENING
REMINDER THAT EVEN AFTER MORE
THAN 1300 AIR STRIKES WITHOUT
INCIDENT OVER IRAQ AND SYRIA,
TROOPS VERY MUCH AT RISK OVER
THE COMBAT ZONE.
RESCUING THE PILOT MAY BE TOUGH
EVEN FOR JORDAN'S HIGHLY
REGARDED COUNTERTERRORISM
FORCES.
IT'S A PROPAGANDA COUP FOR THE
TERRORIST GROUP.
THESE ARE VERY MOTIVATED PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE THEY ARE HOLY
WARRIORS AND THAT THIS IS THEIR
DESTINY TO CREATE AN ISLAMIC
STATE IN THE HEART OF THE ARAB
WORLD AND THEY'LL FIGHT TO THE
DEATH TO PROTECT THAT.
ISIS CLAIMS THEIR HEAT-SEEKING
MISSILES BROUGHT DOWN THE JET,
PUBLISHING THESE IMAGES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA TO MAKE THEIR CASE,
BUT A SENIOR U.S. DEFENSE
OFFICIAL TELLS CNN FOR NOW THERE
ARE NO INDICATIONS THE PLANE WAS
SHOT DOWN.
COALITION AND JORDANIAN
AUTHORITIES CONTINUE
INVESTIGATING WHAT MIGHT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> ISIS CLAIMED THAT IT WAS SHOT
DOWN BY A HEAT-SEEKING MISSILE
WHICH FITS THE PATTERN WITH WHAT
THEY HAVE, BUT IF THE PILOTS ARE
OPERATING ABOVE THAT, THEN THERE
MUST HAVE BEEN SOME OTHER REASON
FOR THE AIRCRAFT TO GO DOWN.
>> THE JORDANIAN GOVERNMENT
WARNED AGAINST HARMING THE
AIRMEN SAYING JORDAN HOLDS THE
TERROR ORGANIZATION AND THOSE
WHO SUPPORT IT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE SAFETY OF THE PILOT AND THE
PRESERVATION OF HIS LIFE.
A SENIOR RETIRED JORDANIAN
COMMAND BELIEVES THERE MAY BE A
SOLUTION.
I'M SURE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS
IN TOUCH WITH THE MEDIATION,
WITH ISIS AND ISIS IS HAS KNOWN
FROM PREVIOUS OCCASIONS TO
PAYMENTS AND A LOT OF MONEY.
IN THAT CASE OR AN EXCHANGE OF
PRISONERS LIKE THAT IS SOMEBODY
OF CONCERN TO ISIS AND AMMAN
MIGHT ASK FOR AN EXCHANGE OR
THEY MIGHT NOT ACCEPT ANYTHING
WHICH WOULD BE REALLY THE
DISASTER IF THEY DECIDED TO DO
THINGS OTHERWISE.
>> BUT